the final departure of the U.S military
after 20 years and their Taliban
adversaries celebrate across Kabul
from multiple guns of all sizes and
description automatic gunfire lit up the
night sky in a rolling thunder
throughout Monday is the evacuation from
the airport continued speculation
mounted about when the U.S would
complete their withdrawal patrolling
aircraft circled over Kabul together
with a B-52 bomber as a steady stream of
Transport planes lumbered off out of
Afghanistan
then soon after midnight local time on
August 31st the days set as the deadline
for the U.S departure the aircraft
sounds died away and as we were on air
word began to spread that the final U.S
aircraft had already lifted off and was
on its way home there's an awful lot of
speculation here at the moment that a
lot of chatter that we may be seeing
finally the end of this evacuation
exercise and if that is the the case
that is the end of the U.S military
involvement in Afghanistan soon
afterwards came the official word from
the U.S pentagon of the end of America's
longest war
I'm here to announce the completion of
our withdrawal from Afghanistan in the
end of the military mission to evacuate
American citizens
Third Country Nationals and vulnerable
afghans
for the first time in two decades there
are no U.S soldiers on Afghan soil to
the Delight of the Taliban many still
disbelieving the pace of developments
that has brought about this Victory
thank God we are here now in control of
the airport and without any problems
thank God but for many Afghans the fear
of what the U.S departure means leaving
them under a future Taliban government
Rob McBride Al Jazeera Kabul